[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans sa conférence de presse tenue
devant 800 journalistes du monde entier
le général de gaulle a abordé les
problèmes de l'algérie du sahara de
bizerte de l'agriculture mais il a avant
tout marqué la position française sur
berlin après les menaces des soviets
ceux ci
veulent par la force
réduire les positions et coupé les
communications
les alliés à berlin
les alliés doivent par la force
maintenir leur position et maintenir
leur communication
assurément de fil en aiguille comme on
dit et si tout cela fait multiplier les
actes hostiles des soviets apte
auxquelles il faudrait répondre
on pourrait en venir
à la guerre générale
mais alors
c'est que les soviets il aurait
délibérément voulue
et dans ce cas tout recul préalable de
l'occident
n'aurait servi qu'à l'affaiblir et à le
diviser
et sans empêcher l'échéance
un certain point de menaces de la part
d'un impérialisme ambitieux
tout recul
a pour effet de surexcités l'agresseur
de le pousser à redoubler sa pression
et finalement
facilite est apte son assaut
au total
actuellement
les puissances occidentales
n'ont pas de meilleur moyen de servir la
paix du monde
que de rester droite et ferme
après l'attentât commis contre la
personne du général de gaulle et dont la
nouvelle avait stupéfié la france et le
monde entier monsieur roger frey
ministre de l'intérieur comment tel
événement devant la presse et en donner
un premier récit détaillé il se
confirmait que c'était sur la route de
collombey entre nogent et romilly
qu'avait été placé une énorme charge
d'explosifs au tas de sable avait servi
à dissimuler une machine infernale dont
une déficience technique à forte
heureusement empêcher le plein
fonctionnement et dont on retrouvait
encore des éléments le land
la déflagration avait été perçue aux
alentours
un double file de 350 mètres enfouis
dans la terre aboutissait à un bosquet
où avait été opéré la mise à feu de ce
bosquet le guetteur on sait qu'il a été
arrêté pouvait embrasser toute la
portion de route de part et d'autre de
l'engin est donné le signal au moment
opportun
[Musique]
le dimanche à colombes et le général de
gaulle l'avait voulu changer en rien ses
habitudes et l'homme qui avait dit après
l'attentât c'est une plaisanterie de
mauvais goût se rendait comme à
l'accoutumée à l'église du village au
milieu de l'émotion qu'on imagine on
imagine aussi l'écho qu'a rencontré le
geste criminel en france car la france
se souvenait elle se souvenait des
tristes heures de l'exode
elle se souvenait de la voix qui
s'étaient élevées pour animer l'espoir
est sans doute ce sont ses souvenirs qui
appartiennent à l'histoire et qui
appartiennent aussi à la légende qui
donne un poids plus lourd encore à la
réprobation que suscite l'attentât
d'aujourd'hui car la france sait ce que
représente l'homme qui avait relevé les
armes de la nation et qui devait tenir
ensuite une place importante dans son
destin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le brésil cette semaine aura été celle
de l'apaisement douze jours après la
démission sensationnel du président
antoine roth 12 jours qui ont vu le
brésil au bord de la guerre civile le
vice président monsieur zhao bollaert a
pu finalement rentré à brasilia au tour
dont l'aspect triomphale est à la mesure
de l'inquiétude ressentie
pour accéder au poste suprême que lui
réservent à la constitution monsieur
goulard a dû accepter la décision du
congrès d'abandonner le régime
présidentiel est de faire du brésil la
première république parlementaire du
nouveau monde il s'agit d'un compromis
sans doute mais le brésil respire
la sphère de bizerte entre hôtels dans
la voie du règlement c'est dans l'écho
des paroles prononcées par le président
bourguiba dont le ton nouveau a détendu
les relations franco tunisiennes que
s'est déroulée à menzel jemil dans le no
man's land entre les deux barrages les
changes des prisonniers sous l'égide de
la croix-rouge
740 soldats et civils tunisiens ont été
remis par les troupes françaises
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de leur côté les tunisiens rendait la
liberté à 220 français 184 civils et 36
militaires
de la grande bretagne cette semaine aura
été celle des regards levés vers le ciel
à farnborough où se tient chaque année
le salon de l'aviation britannique
l'exposition statique ne manquait certes
pas d'intérêt on ya vu notamment le
bluestreak qui sera le premier étage de
la première fusée européenne de
recherche spatiale
[Musique]
mais ce sont les présentations entre
elles qui ont comme d'habitude retenu
l'attention mondiale en général et
soviétique en particulier
[Applaudissements]
du reste les hélicoptères à usage
militaire n'avait plus rien à apprendre
à personne non plus que le short et ses
seins à décollage vertical qui n'en est
pas à son coup d'essai mais demeure en
raison de son étrangeté une attraction
in et puiser
il reste que la participation des
parachutistes britanniques à apporter à
la grande parade de farnborough des
moments de sa vie d'émotion tels ces
sauts groupe est de 60 secondes de chute
libre
il reste aussi qu'on a vu pour la
première fois en vol le mvp 115 la
flèche violente prototypes des
long-courriers supersonique de demain
[Applaudissements]
il reste enfin qu'avec et patrouille
acrobatique de la royal air force les
ailes britanniques ont donné une image
saisissante de l'aviation d'aujourd'hui
m
à bruxelles nous avons surpris ce
cuisinier affairés autour de ses
fourneaux mais le dernier plat ranger
pourquoi échanges qu'ils s'attaquent
contre un chapeau de cowboy
[Musique]
nous avons surpris aussi ce directeur de
société qui ferme ses dossiers à la fin
d'une journée épuisante
pourquoi chose il soudain des bottes
[Musique]
les + dim personnage de bruxelles serait
il saisit par la manie du travesti
voici l'explication à tremelo à 35 km de
bruxelles c'est texas city un far west
de fantaisie ou un club peu banale
français quelques 80 membres un ersatz
de la vie des cowboys on a paraît-il
rien trouvé de mieux pour effacer les
effets déprimant de notre vie moderne
des magistrats des hommes d'affaires des
restaurateurs des ouvriers viennent
qu'ils abandonnent leur personnalité
pour retrouver leurs rêves dansants ne
s'appelle plus que james hook bill
rien ne manque à texas city ni les
chevaux ni les fusils ni le classique
saloon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le notaire tire le cuisinier riposte
l'avocat c'est cool et le
président-directeur général en profite
pour remporter la caisse
et tous ces joyeux personnages
ressuscite pour danser le quadrille des
pionniers
qu'on se garde de jeter un jugement trop
hâtif c'est peut-être pour les surmené
la solution de l'avenir
[Musique]
aux jeux équestres de rotterdam en
hollande les garçons de piste ont eu
beaucoup de travail cavaliers et chevaux
s'en sont donné à coeur joie le concours
d'obstacles s'est rapidement transformée
en petit jeu de massacre
[Musique]
de temps à autre pour ne pas faire comme
tout le monde certains concurrents
franchissent le mur sans bavure presque
par inadvertance
on augmente la difficulté
le mur est à deux mètres 10 c'est encore
un peu plus de travail en perspective
pour les garçons de piste voilà qui est
fait
ce cavalier en revanche a l'air de
vouloir rompre la monotonie que le saut
est impeccable chapeau monsieur
[Musique]
sofia à l'heure des universiades les
universiades ce sont en quelque sorte
jeux olympiques réservé aux étudiants de
tous les pays du monde la gymnastique
constitue l'une des épreuves les plus
spectaculaires qui soit
le japonais mitsui pour y réaliser un
exploit dans les exercices au sol
limitée par cette jeune fille soviétique
[Musique]
des gymnastes soviétique c'était
d'ailleurs la part du lion dans chaque
spécialité titoff en cheval d'arçons de
quoi vous donner le tournis
[Musique]
titoff encore aux anneaux cette fois
[Applaudissements]
en
pour n'être pas en reste le japonais
mitsui courir revient lui aussi une
seconde fois il est aussi brillant à la
barre fixe que dans les exercices au sol
[Musique]
les double barre c'est le royaume des
gymnastes féminines et particulièrement
des soviétiques
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
n'ont elles pas autant de charme ces
jeunes filles que les reines de beauté
des plages de la mode
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]